john you and i are best friends
for never oh no
peacemakers season one episode two
i am so excited man that first episode
was great great stuff thanks thank god
for jimmy gunn and john cena guys if you
can subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next peacemaker
episode is up and that would be a rad a
sandwich of a time also please go ahead
and hit that like button it sure helps
us out in the algorithm full length
watch along where you sync up with the
timecode for peacemaker over at our
patreon special thank you to all who
have become superjects so far cover a
bunch of shows over there as well lastly
thanks to the boys at prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
let's get to it
well we got a situation here what i
hooked up with a chick and i'm not
saying that to make you jealous i'm
saying it because she was a metahuman
shriek that threw me around the room
like an angry kid with his little
sister's cabbage patch doll oh [ __ ]
all right i'm on my way let me give you
the address
i can track you through the chip in your
head wait
you can't see me jerk off that thing can
you
new girl you're driving peacemaker just
killed a damn butterfly
peacemaker's vehicles at the scene can
you change the name on the registration
yep good
okay i actually see them do some mission
stuff mm-hmm the report said an
explosion
how'd the possum stay intact i hope this
isn't some cape [ __ ] that is in scary
movie yeah and riverdale
oh
[ __ ] you believe this idiot [ __ ] the
butterfly i mean the man's been in
prison for four years there's not much i
believe he wouldn't [ __ ]
a bowl of oatmeal
grapefruit
some yogurt
what
roll down the window stick your hand
outside and then crinkle a bag he'll
think you have chips he'll come right
out to you why are you feeding him chips
is that somebody in the window up there
[ __ ] jeez come on man
there's no exit on the back of the
building so see if you can get to a
balcony on the second floor and jump
jump
you can handle it yeah he's he sounded a
lot worse than that
hey man what's up
uh freddy there freddie who freddie
momma no there's no you guys are doing
shard dance charcuterie right and yeah
sorry about the evite you guys sent me a
uh ponder it's flinderer teddy grinder
no
no knock on doors
[ __ ] man please pick him up okay okay
okay
evan what's going on
i just want to talk to you straight from
like one human being to another i'll die
of claustrophobia if i get tied up so
yeah
sure
easter really loves cinderella yeah tom
key from the boys like the perfect mix
of blues metal
[ __ ] yeah yeah
oh no
you just never [ __ ] hear me because
you're always going out about cool
playing fuss with the [ __ ] people oh
you're gonna put down my musical taste
now how [ __ ] low are you pumped up
kicks evan do you know what that song is
about murder
yeah yeah i'm trying to [ __ ] this really
cool handsome guy right in front of me i
am not trying to find him i thought you
know what happened oh my god maybe i
will who knows what's gonna [ __ ]
happen right because i'm tied up i'm
helpless i mean anything could [ __ ]
happen right i mean seriously you're
[ __ ] knocked out
oh no
there he is
ouch
[Music]
he's not racist
see
i'm gonna destroy the discs man yeah
[Music]
stop you've gotta have a better landing
after all this time
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
do not move step forward and into the
light
what a way to phrase that too
oh oh damn she's super hot hey
come
on harcourt
[Music]
i don't really emphasize how heavy he is
too in the sound design
i tell you i'm so worried that eagle's
going to die i know
so i changed the fingerprints out to the
same person which they'll discover when
they get the lab results back in a
couple days great who'd you change it to
oh mr martin you're gonna love this
oh my god yes
your kid hasn't christopher smith
peacemaker
arrest me or get the [ __ ] out of here
chopsticks yeah well we'll be seeing you
fork fork
why not spoon
everybody in the world uses spoons that
[ __ ] doesn't know that
that's true
and this boom would have been more
demeaning yeah makes it like a baby
thing you know little babies use spoons
okay adults also use spoons but i get it
we're trying to get this man on our side
and you thought the right way to do that
was to frame his father
my adrenaline's pumping
pumping like glass breaking everything
you ever been shot at
no
[Laughter]
i'd rather be with [ __ ] batmite than
you that's batman the two-foot tall
inter-dimensional imp who stands batman
you're gonna see him before the season's
over i trust her the most because he
liked it he tried to bite me yeah but
not as hard as he tries to fight
everybody else it's obviously uh
elmo
economist [ __ ] you
why do all of you have such weird last
names
hanging out having some fun maybe doing
some fentanyl with a prostitute in the
back of a hillbilly strip club he's
following love because it's obviously
the first time he's put his balls in
somebody's mouth and he starts getting
loose lips i'm on a team with the famous
peacemaker and we're taking down the
notorious butterflies my beard's real
my beard's real sounds more plausible
than i wish it did what i don't even
like when my balls are in somebody's
mouth okay it gives me the wrong type of
chills
how long it's been since i've gotten
checked for testicular cancer
too
long
evan and amber calcuttara can you take
care of him just convince him not to
finger peacemaker huh
more like um
i have no clue
i still don't know what that is
leota pay them
bribery yes please go do it now
[Laughter]
he's straight with me man i'm a dick
vampire
no you're not a dick vampire you're just
a dick
why would they just tell them what they
are who cares about keeping the peace
yeah if they're a threat it'll keep the
peace at this point it might be safer
than giving him a glossy i used to leap
around
buddy you killed rick flag
oh
what are you doing are you looking at me
and jerking off right now is your dick
out
what no no man look i'm not gonna
[ __ ] look the oldest trick in the
book i look can you [ __ ] rock hard
you throw jizz in my face no [ __ ] way
is that what you get off on me seeing
your [ __ ] dick
who the [ __ ] said that louis ck piece of
[ __ ]
you show people your dick what does that
have to do with louis c.k's comedy
specials i didn't say [ __ ] about his
comedy
well i don't [ __ ] know i'm just
trying to figure out the connection dude
louis c.k showed people's dick
firstly i'm wondering whether you saw
the guy in your apartment that you think
you saw or did you maybe see another guy
that you actually didn't see what you
think you did
i'm wondering if you've ever had an
all-expenses paid trip to the beautiful
lake tahoe nevada
are you trying to [ __ ] bribe us no
oh
just hoping you're trying to bribe us
yeah yeah i'm trying to bribe you
[Laughter]
when i find out someone murdered an
innocent person or sold somebody heroin
or did some graffiti and i kill that
person my bare hands their eyeballs
popping out of their skull
[Laughter]
it gives you pleasure too peacemaker
that's because we're born killers what
separates us from other killers is we
only kill bad people
usually
what do you say we celebrate you getting
out of prison no i have to study the
dossier the center i gotta kill
i've been saving up appliances ever
since you were arrested
oh really i got fire for a heart and
that's good
that's what i'm talking about do this
ah they get along we need a bonding
exercise like this
[Music]
be careful guys
[Applause]
[Music]
it's this guy are you sure
yeah
oh god damn jeez what are they thinking
jesus christ you again
august smith you are under arrest for
the murder of annie sterpalzen i don't
even know who the [ __ ] that is
that's not good oh boy
[Music]
oh my god
what the [ __ ] dude
holy [ __ ]
what
there's definitely some horseplay
holy [ __ ]
the white dragon
hey
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
i mean like
you knew you just didn't know
crap
so yeah they handled that ending
remarkably well you're like think at
least in my mind i'm watching it like
okay here comes the cliche yeah they're
gonna pick a fight he's gonna whoop some
ass yeah yeah i was literally thinking
where are we about to get the robert
patrick fight scene yeah and how is his
martial arts gonna be and yeah what a
reveal yeah
oh man
great use of tension because it's still
there's still like a punch at the end
but it's a great subversion of the
expertise
that they are uh liberal army uh-huh
yeah they're social justice warriors all
of them warriors
they're about to go cancel a bunch of
people a few all about what culture
they're problematic that's crazy did not
see that reveal coming when that
occurred
it's crazy how they're like building up
the first episode does such a great job
at introducing like a tone in the
characters and getting you acquainted at
like hooking you into the heart and then
this one
for a second episode really throws you
thrusts you like into
the exciting adventures back to you know
like the the first
i don't know 15 20 minutes of this
episode i don't know how long but of him
trying to escape from the apartment
building and the shenanigans he runs
into and i like the
the
you know it's like but he was there's
gonna be it's gonna get more crazy it's
gonna get crazier still in the world of
dc it's including some spaceship at the
end or something that you had right now
um
but for the most part you know like as
much as
peacemaker is a
more ele like a heightened character in
the suicide squad because
we see him as comedic elements we see
how like ridiculous of an assassin he is
and how insane his accuracy at shooting
is and such
and like the confidence of killing have
you never really gone in that yet with
him yeah of like that scene where you
know i'm kind of imagining when him and
bloodsport are uh you know
you know doing dick measuring contest
with killing people we haven't gotten a
scene like that of him yet no of where
he's just this like confident assassin
yeah yeah and uh so we were we saw the
first episode with ended on that fight
and then here to go into like when he's
trying to escape and i like the
i like that i just picked up immediately
after like there was no time jump he's
not just meeting back up it feels like
you you're watching like the
continuation of the first episode
and um and yeah when he's escaping and
like the i've you've seen that so many
actually like hop in balconies and stuff
but i like the realistic version of that
like it's just never a good landing for
it it's a great device for both comedy
and stunts because it is like there it
is impressive but not because it's cool
because it's painful yeah and it's
sloppy and it emphasizes just how big he
is and how ill-suited he is like i i
appreciate that i think too because you
see a lot of like big bulky heroes and
whatnot and there's always this sort of
treatment of the physics as if they
aren't as big as they are and so i love
that while he is very proficient at
certain things he's also very clunky at
other agility bases yeah yeah you're
very true and i was thinking during that
sequence i was like oh how
smart
it is you know in the structuring
because just you know imagining the
structure of a movie is one thing and
then the structure of a show is a whole
other thing and it felt like yeah it
flowed perfectly out of the last episode
and
naturally sets up a great opening action
set piece that is actually tense and and
exemplifies like what you were talking
about last episode was just how great
james gunn is at uh you know weaving
between the tones and building tension
while also releasing it sometimes at the
same time like i feel like the bit in
the apartment with the couple could have
been tedious and could have been like
okay haha like i get it we're trying to
make this quirky but it like actually
kind of pulls you in and then those
characters show up later and like
there's yeah like
it's really fun and it's really easy to
get into but it's also like doing a lot
of pretty solid sophisticated
storytelling in the process i feel like
and also setting the stage for harcourt
to like show her real bras she's great
she's so badass in fact i was looking
for a name this whole time you just said
it yeah yeah
no no we got to give hp max of that
extra bit of watch time um oh wait
there's probably a post credit scene
oh yes you're correct
all right
well if you're watching the stream
online
uh maybe we'll just tack it on at the
end
put these headphones back on he just
realized that
he's definitely not the hot guy
[ __ ] you amber oh eat me evan
okay
can i keep this one
sure
[Laughter]
comedy say go we caught that yeah
otherwise it could have been bad
a lot of people thought this is the
comments that's right i wonder if like
one of these post credit scenes will
actually be like super important
and it'll be a random episode yeah so
you'll never know episode four um yeah
and then how this episode in particular
started fleshing out more of the
relationship dynamics amongst everyone
like the introduction of adrian chase
got him last episode but
a more psychopathic version of even
peacemaker himself that lie that that
delivery on that one
like or if someone's graffiti
i have to murder them
so you knew it was coming but yeah the
delivery was just
squeezed
and then a call back with their smoke
and then joint together and it's it's
funny because that
is something that this show is obviously
going to do over the course of the arc
of all the episodes is deconstruct you
know
how much of a psychopath chris really is
but i i appreciated that scene for the
fact that it is this this bonding moment
and it is kind of a pep talk and even
though it's definitely like
yeah vigilante's a bit of a is a bit of
a psycho yeah at the same time uh it
doesn't necessarily bring up that like
confrontation immediately it's not like
peacemakers like whoa wait you're a
psycho yeah you know and so it it i like
if that's part of the james gun charm i
think is is getting into those in
between spaces where it's like there's
something endearing here there's also
something kind of messed up here yeah
you know and uh and their whole like
little bro moment shooting stuff in the
woods like that was a very much fun well
the way he uses the camera is so
impressive here because
it's not exactly like
in terms of like director of photography
it's not like super popping in the
colors and stuff
that's what keeps it feeling more
grounded and a little bit more realistic
it's not it's not hyper stylizing the
color palette of it all like the things
look it looks good but it's not like
sleek you know
yet he knows how to really utilize like
how to handle reveals on certain shots
even the shot when he jumps down to the
dumpster you know like the camera is
like pointed up and he jumps down and
then slowly pulls back like very it's
very minimal to the point where you can
see the dumpster after he like as he's
about to land
um they make a lot of wide angle lenses
both yeah it's really impressive yeah
and especially with blocked camera
motion whether that be some really fluid
like you know just uh pan or transition
or track or whatever or things like that
where yeah it's like this looks like
it's just going to be one static shot
but then yeah based on the blocking of
the acting and whatnot that there's
going to be a strategic move and yeah
it's like the sleek
elements come out through that use of
motion more so yeah than like the crazy
colors or anything like that i think
it's a good blend because it has
a rhythm to its visual style without
feeling like hey
yeah yeah yeah it doesn't feel like he
should weirdly it's like even though
this is a show and he can do whatever it
wants he doesn't feel like he's ever
showing off yeah surprisingly and i
thought there'd be a little bit more of
that and yet he just seems like no he's
telling the story that needs to be told
and and uh and the flow that it needs to
be done i feel like he's showing off by
having
by doing again what he did with like
suicide squad where it's just like this
is like really engaging character driven
and fun and getting wild and kooky and
kind of tense and yeah it's like
i think the show off is really just all
this balancing because yeah
there would be so much license to go
crazy and make it as slick as possible
in every way
because even though you know the suicide
squad isn't the most successful you know
movie
wb has produced lately you know i still
feel like they would give them that room
and so that restraint i think helps a
lot i mean the show was being filmed
beforehand yeah before it even got
released also very true yeah but even so
like it's it's it's conceived at least
thus far in a way that makes a lot of
sense and it feels like yeah i could see
how you could make this a show without
uh feeling too constricted and not
needing a ton of money and resources
because like the butterfly from the
first episode was certainly like a whoa
and it was certainly like a jump into
height but you know thus far it's still
pretty grounded even as such well it's
all about budgeting i think he's really
good at
like
sometimes i can't tell what is
sometimes seem like this seems
improvised yeah but other times like
it's almost like something he would
write yeah the whole bit about like
louis c.k
yeah oh yeah definitely
like making fun of that part like the
sometimes when the banter is going on
for a long period of time
you could really that's why i start to
question it but the way things tie back
into each other
yeah
it's got such a great rhythm to it that
you would think that
maybe it is written and i think he knows
how to like blend that really well in
the when it's when it comes time to
editing
and yeah it's like we got excited to see
peacemaker uh
at a bio really love her like she's so
sweet and so hilarious
and
you get this
this sense of what i like how he he
tends to
he tends to flip tropes on their head in
ways you might not expect like the last
thing i expected was added bio to the
way she's responding to things like
while she is reacting to the danger and
the circumstances of that like with her
wife in the hotel
you know like when it comes to the
getting shot at she's like this is kind
of exciting yeah i think that's a really
great way to handle the character yeah
100 she's a good blend between the
audience cipher but also you know one of
these heightened characters and even the
introduction of the cops too
like how do you make these cops so
interesting like like pairing these two
up and there's something that's so
straightforward about them like there's
nothing really that i can't quite
pinpoint what is so unique about them it
could just be like the solid acting and
the solid pairing of the chemistry of
them but you could feel that there's
more to these characters already
as the show will progress you can feel
there's already more to them that makes
them engaging as opposed to just
generic boring-ass cops that they bring
into here
um holland
freaking awesome it's like so i'm like i
want to know about her past
because it's cool that she's like
someone who's really good at being
behind the computer handling all that
investigative [ __ ] um you think she's
someone who's just doing tech or
whatever other stuff that they do on the
staff at task force x yeah then come to
find out she's actually this like
skilled assassin at the same time too
yeah and the way how she like keeps her
cool and certainly like she gets
frustrated upset but like the little
subtle details when they're driving in
the car and like she's you know usually
like at
a bio like that has to swerve out of the
way and almost hit someone and she when
she's just doing her gun like cleaning
and fix putting the gun together
usually you know the charac the
passenger carrying the passengers people
have like some reaction to it she's just
she's
like especially a character like her
who's like been bitching a lot and then
like yeah really upset about a lot of
these flustered rests
yeah you know but when it comes time to
handle business like just a little
subtle detail like attention detail and
a character moment like that are the
things that really stand out more to me
than anything else
because it's those little nuances that
help the bigger things really shine and
like the bigger things being john cena's
amazing performance john cena is in an
incredible in here like
like i remember raving about him with
the suicide squad of like this is the
first time i really just believe him as
a character and not seeing john cena
and because he's invisible you guys get
it
[Music]
but here he's he is he's just
found such life to this character you
know honestly even
when watching the suicide squad as great
as i thought he was in it
i didn't think i could
i had a hard time imagining like oh yeah
of course i trust james gunn yeah
johnson is good but can but a show oh
you might want to spend like six to
eight hours this guy but throwing him
into the shoes where he really is like
the the joke and how he the way they
managed to explore how he just looks for
he wants to belong like his whole
character is just someone who really
just wants to be validated
and the way how they've dealt with that
at a way that doesn't feel like it's
going against the suicide squad is one
of the more impressive parts to me
because it doesn't necessarily feel like
we're doing a deconstruction it just
feels like we're exploring who this guy
really is
through these challenges yeah and then
even him questioning like everything
he's ever stood for he gets out of
prison his dad hates him he gets
assigned to stuff they don't trust him
they don't even bother to tell him what
the mission's about everyone just keeps
clowning on him as much as he's trying
he keeps messing up they have like made
more of like a childish buffoonery about
the guy where i'm like he's i feel like
he'll be a little bit more on top of
things
yeah
there's much of it yeah like i i've seen
the suicide squad twice in the theaters
um i haven't seen it at home yet i'm
trying to recall if uh
if that kind of lines like he's a he's a
little dumb when it comes to mission
stuff he seems really on top of it but
we also didn't get enough of like like
when he's like banging that woman and he
leaves the file out like that his
character do that
that's fair yeah because in this
in my current recollection of the
suicide squad i get the sense that i got
the sense he's a guy with that juvenile
sense of humor but yeah who is a little
more reliable
reliably aware you know yeah of the
tactical uh importances and advantages
and disadvantages and whatnot yeah
whereas here i i
right now it does seem like yeah they've
heightened
the idiot part of him
yeah because we haven't really gotten a
chance to really see the capable side of
him of why they want him yeah yeah other
than his great ability for killing which
he hasn't on their mission plan been
called to use even yet but on a um
on a character level what i can see
happening is
what's actually putting him out of his
comfort zone at being great a yeah of
course as a broken the clavicle yeah
that is messed up i'm sure
he's been questioning his he's having
kind of an existential crisis at the
moment
yes but i think what probably might be
bringing out of him even more is the
fact that he's
in his hometown um you know like so i
think there is where you feel the most
like a kid yeah where he could be the
most prone to you know resorting back to
what's really going on underneath and
not even realizing it
so that's one quality to it yeah where
it's like he's becoming he's behaving
more like the way how his dad views him
mm-hmm
yeah falling into that projection yeah
yeah so i think like on a character
level
um there's a way to justify it that i
think does make sense that i don't feel
i'm actually fully filling in the blank
because i even i was like
you know in while watching so just tell
what the mission's about he's all about
peace you know and then he brought it
back later in this exact episode where
he's like crying about like he he killed
rick flagg he obviously doesn't think he
should have done that
and uh he's like peacemaker is a joke
you know like this whole thing so i
they're doing a good job at taking the
events of that not just trying to be
like we're just you know referencing
we're rebooting
peacemaker to make them a hero like
they're not doing that they still make
him like like he grabs girls underwear
as this and on the way out like he still
and he's still juvenile and he's still
not a great person
um but they they have made him really
he is very likable like it's it's pretty
crazy like how likable he is yeah i i
weirdly i think that the scene in the
previous episode
sums it up well when he stops it on
harcourt at the bar
and he stops the creeps but then also
proceeds to creep in just a slightly
different way and i feel like that is
sort of a good representation
of the kind of character that he is
because yeah you do have those elements
that are still like
you got progress to make my friends but
also yeah you don't mean uh you don't
mean ill you don't have uh you you know
you don't come from a place of malice or
or you know genuinely wanting to you
know make people uncomfortable yeah it's
more like that part of the o fish
obliviousness does track i think pretty
well sure sure um yeah and shout outs
out to see beige you can kill killing it
in the comedic role and i keep wondering
about abu dhabi if they're gonna at a
bio if they're gonna
like arc her and to be a little bit more
like amanda waller she'll be the new
amanda waller moving
that's all this is flash reboots
everything yeah
it completely eliminates all the events
of peacemaker
enjoy it while it lasts peeps
all right guys well uh thank you so much
for being here um you can subscribe
click that bell
and i will catch you in the next episode